on vous le dit une fois de temps en
temps on va regarder dans le rétroviseur
pour parler de bidules du passé avec
notre collègue jean tremblay qui vont
nous parler de son cimetière de gadgets
et puis cette semaine je nique on va
parler d'un ordinateur que les moins de
30 ans ne peuvent simplement pas comme
un hors jeu vous donner des indices sur
tous les auditeurs vous savez de quoi il
s'agit mais c'est un ordinateur qui
était commercialisé en 1982 qui avait le
chiffre ici est important 64 ko de
mémoire on pouvait le brancher sur la
télé mais aussi sur un très beau
moniteur l'ordinateur coûter 600 dollars
mais avec le lecteur de disquettes 5
pouces et quand on ne rit plus et le
moniteur ça coûtait ça coûterait plus de
2000 $ mais c'était moins cher que des
ordinateurs d'apple ou ibm qui avait
pourtant moins de mémoire eux donc pour
ceux qui l'ont pas deviné on écoute une
publicité du temps
parfois les derniers plans de magasins
il tente tout ça
plus encore avec encore
oui toute une génération notamment avec
les jeux on lisait beaucoup j'en ai
parlé avec l'informaticien yves des
fossés qui vendait cet ordinateur les ya
appris à programmer sur commodore 64
retour sur l'image avec lui
ce qui était vraiment exceptionnel sur
le commodore 64 c'était la partie audio
le commodore 64 était à munich si moi je
pense qu'il y en avait trois et ça
permettait d'avoir un sons polyphoniques
vous pouviez avoir
la musique où il y avait deux
instruments ou même trois instruments
qui jouait en même temps et à la ce a
donné un son symphonique
je me souviens de la compagnie épique ce
qui était vraiment en avance côté
programmation de ces choses là dans ces
années là epix en fait entre autres la
série des des jeux d'hiver des jeux
olympiques
et il y avait à l'intérieur de
l'application l'ensemble des hymnes
nationaux
moi j'étais plutôt un amateur de
baseball mais sean
holmes est mission impossible aussi mais
ça faut le dire mission impossible
la fluidité de jeu l'inter remarquable
en fait je pense que ça a pris 5 avant
que je retrouve un autre jeu qui avait
la même fluidité des personnages à la
face on entre dans le sillon est
possible où le personnage sautet faisait
des saltos avant c'était absolument fr 1
canal comme 264 le flash et kuyt
économies dans les familles on vote le
budget de la rentrée éducation les
professeurs sinus et caussinus en cents
à domicile merci de votre attention ce
journal était réalisée avec le
micro-ordinateur commodore 64
récemment j'ai changé de la carte de
mémoire dans mon téléphone j'ai mis une
carte de 32 go si on le faisait en
disque est pour le commodore 64 ça
prendrait l'équivalent en espace de deux
gourous un réfrigérateur en termes d'
espaces de disque est parce qu une boîte
de disque est donné à peu près
l'équivalent de 3 méga octets de
l'espace c'était dans le cas où ceux qui
sont viendront les disquettes avait la
possibilité d'être lu seulement d'un
côté non payées point sony exactement
dont le deuxième côté dépôts garantis
mais finalement ça fonctionnait toujours
peut-être la dernière question que je
vous poserai il des fossés c
rétrospectivement cet ordinateur lequel
importance il ya pu avoir et ce que vous
pensez que ça a pu susciter des
carrières ou un intérêt plus marqué vers
l'informatique moi j'ai pas de doute que
le commodore 64 et et la plate forme de
départ de beaucoup de gens moi compris
dans ces années là j'étais intéressé à
l'informatique mais j'ai commencé à
programmer sur le commodore 64
parce que j'ai pu prouver que je savais
programmée l'été capable d'avoir un
travail d'été de stagiaires en
programmation sur les premiers ibm et le
reste comme on dit c'est l'histoire
merci beaucoup il déposer sa fille
d'avoir partagé ça avec nous
que de souvenirs mais on se souvient
aussi que c'était pas très facile de
faire du traitement de texte avec un
écran j'ai seulement quarante caractères
une page c'est 80 donc deux lignes des
cross est une seule ligne tapie une fois
le document imprimé stebbins beau mais
stebbins compliqué toutefois c'est un
ordinateur qui s'est vendu beaucoup 1,22
million d'exemplaires et qui vit encore
à travers les sites et les clubs de
rétro gaming sciemment sévit encore tout
le temps merci jeunes étrangers